all companies are media companies they
just don't know it yet so the the old
days of you making commercials and
trying to gain influence and persuade
people
and making impact on their purchasing
and the decisions that they make
it seems to be almost over so you might
as well start to learn how to create
content
in a way that you can speak directly to
your audience
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm so fired up for today's episode
where we're going to be talking about
how to grow your youtube channel
youtube shorts and learning from chris
doe now if you're just meeting chris
he's an emmy award-winning
designer director ceo and chief
strategist of blind and the founder
of the future i mean we're talking over
1.5 million subscribers on youtube
12 million views a month on their
channel right now
uploading videos daily but also just a
real
businessman a real entrepreneur a real
creative entrepreneur
that has wisdom from every stage of the
journey
building a company building social media
influence
helping and impacting people coaching
people and i'm super honored to have
chris on the show
today chris how's it going it's going
great sean
this is a long time coming i think we've
been chasing each other on the table
trying to play tag
the day is finally here it is and i'm
super pumped to have you on uh the
podcast today
and grateful for the impact that you're
making in the world what you do
um is is really powerful and the future
specifically
is such a powerful brand business
youtube channel it's a lot more than a
youtube channel
if people are just hearing about that
what pa paint the picture of what you
guys do on youtube but maybe start with
like the vision of the the company
itself
and um what you guys are up to sure
thanks for teaming that up
our mission is very clear which is to
teach a billion people how to make a
living
doing what they love and this is really
critical to me because i now
identify myself more as a teacher and
the entrepreneurship is just kind of
the icing on the cake i'm really trying
to make a difference in the world
i taught at art center for 15 years
teaching
sequential design graphic design motion
graphics and directing
but the problem with that is as much as
i love that experience
it wasn't scalable and it was very
limited to a people who could afford to
go to this school
to live in los angeles and that meant a
very small group of people
so i had this hypothesis could we teach
this same stuff
virtually at scale one to many
and it took a little while to find the
rhythm to kind of understand how you
teach online
and i just want to tip my hat to you
watching some of your videos figuring
out like god this guy's smooth
he is so smooth on camera and he
delivers so succinctly
i had to learn from that and once i did
i started to find a rhythm and to build
an audience
man so powerful and i love the vision
teach
1 billion people how to make a living
doing what they love
and one of the vehicles you have chosen
is youtube why invest
so heavily in youtube back when you
started
and would you recommend people lean
heavily into youtube with all the
options out there today
what's the why behind youtube simple
answer is in 2014 i'm a social media
neophyte i don't really understand
social media i have accounts but i'm not
really doing anything with it
and i do what most people do you post an
occasional thing that you eat
something that you do with your family
some cool place you've been to
and so i do what everybody does and i
commit the cardinal sin
and it was when i met my former business
partner jose cabelle
who said let's make some content on
youtube to help bring awareness to a
course that we were teaching
nobody knows who we are nobody
understands the course they don't even
understand the problem
so reluctantly in 2014 at the ripe old
age of 42
i say yes and in doing so i go on this
crazy journey
it transforms my life it transforms my
business and it
realigned what my purpose is would i
recommend youtube today to anybody
absolutely yes and the reason why is
because of the
powerful search engine on most social
platforms
the content you create is very ephemeral
it's there and then it's gone
whereas youtube if you create the right
kind of content it can be evergreen
videos that we created three four five
six years ago are still being seen today
and every once in a while we get really
lucky one of them gets rediscovered
man i love that and that is one of our
favorite uh
powerful attributes of youtube we
believe it's the only platform or really
is one of the only platforms where your
content lives forever if you do it right
your content is like a fine wine it gets
better with age
um and as entrepreneurs one of the most
powerful things to embrace
is leverage right we want to have a
return on investment for our time so if
we can ask ourselves
what could i do today that would
actually give me more time
tomorrow youtube can be one of those
uh powerful platforms that does that
are you aware of how many videos you
have uploaded to the channel
so far last count i think is around 1300
so it's quite a few videos and
what was the growth curve um you started
investing like you said kind of back in
2014
but was it instant overnight success or
has it been like a snowball
growing in momentum it's more like a
snowflake that takes years to turn into
a little snowball
so this path has been long and it's been
arduous but
one thing i would love to tell all
content creators is do it for the love
learn to love to play the game not for
the championship trophy because if you
do it for that reason
when you don't get the results that
you're hoping for you get discouraged
and then you kind of drop
out so for me more than anything it was
a journey on self-discovery
about how to find my voice as an
introvert it was very difficult to step
in front of the camera
i was much more comfortable behind the
camera so learning just to do that even
being able to introduce myself and say
my name
and my title was a challenge at the
beginning but it's well worth it
it took us forever to get to twenty
thousand subscribers and forty thousand
hundred thousand
but if you keep doing the work you get
better you you ask yourself this one
or two questions what did i do well and
what can i do better and you apply those
lessons forward
don't worry about the view count don't
worry about the followers or subscribers
that doesn't matter right now just try
to get better every single day
and you'll start to to realize the the
benefits of the compound effect
what did i do well what could i do
better speaking of that question
looking back now um what are some things
that you wish you knew
when first starting this is maybe an
invitation to share some of your tips
for creating uh content or just
practical
youtube tips that you've learned in the
journey maybe how you even
get videos done or how you optimize
videos if i knew then
what i knew now this is what i would
have done differently what are a few of
those tips chris
the first tip would be to try to have
the intentionality to make impact on
people's lives
don't go out there to pitch to sell to
be overly entertaining
it's not a vanity project think about
your audience what it is that they need
and how you can help them to bridge a
gap that means you have to be able to
identify the audience to understand
a challenge that they're having an
obstacle that is preventing them from
going to the next level
the next level could be small or it
could be big for us it was about helping
creative people understand different
strategies about pricing
or how to talk about sales that is an
organic way that
doesn't feel like you're losing your
soul once we figure that out we can then
figure out
what is the best format to deliver this
in for us we found
great success in doing these whiteboard
or
flip chart episodes where we can draw
and we can diagram
and it gives some visual interest for
the audience to follow along
it is very difficult for someone to
maintain attention
especially with this adhd culture that
we have for a
very long period of time without
something happening in the scene so
talking heads or even beautifully
designed keynote presentations
are tough to watch so try to have
visual demonstrations something that you
can do with your hands
so that the audience stays intrigued
because you have to keep them if you
want to reach them
brilliant tips and uh man holding
attention
is one of the big factors of youtube
that average view iteration that
audience retention
and considering how you can do visuals
now what it
it's kind of like asking the expert
at design how important design is but
for those that are maybe new to chris
and listening to this just on audio
um essentially his superpower one of
is is design they've worked for nike and
big brands and
uh billboards graphic design their
thumbnails and the aesthetic
of their channel of course as they
should be are pretty incredible
uh chris how do you think that comes
into social media but specifically
youtube
thumbnails the visuals aesthetic what's
the importance of that
i think the visuals are important but i
i know i'm betraying my tribe by saying
as a visual designer as a graphic
designer as a director
actually the writing the the actual
content
what you say and what you hear are more
important
than the way it looks and i've i think
i've heard you say this before that
high value content beats high value
production i 100
agree with that so if you have an iphone
if you have some junky camera
it doesn't matter make sure you're
thinking through
planning and organizing your content in
a way that's going to make the maximum
amount of
impact on the people who are watching
this it doesn't matter if it's a podcast
a video or
an instagram carousel think about them
start with really good writing i find
that a lot of times when people create
content on youtube
they don't do the minimal amount of
research
just type in your topic read a few
articles to have an informed opinion
so that you're not just making stuff up
and it's not just opinion based
i think that's where a lot of youtube
falls into this trap
great advice now i'm so excited to talk
about youtube shorts
i've been watching our whole team at
think media has been watching what you
guys are doing at
uh the future and we've been blown away
because there's that one short you
posted where you're having a
conversation about pricing
that is just going absolutely viral
um it's now your most viewed video on
your channel right it has 22 million
views at the time of recording this
the top three videos on your channel
you've been doing youtube
for like seven years plus but the top
three
most viewed videos on your channel are
youtube shorts and youtube shorts has
not been a long
uh been around that long i'm curious
what have you been learning
with youtube shorts we could go deep on
this one
how how heavily are you investing in
youtube shorts maybe take us through the
story did you just
start experimenting and get lucky with
that video is there some intentionality
um what's your hot take on youtube
shorts
i want to give credit where credit's due
i was having a conversation with brian
elliot he has a youtube channel called
behind the brand
and we're just talking and sharing ideas
what's working for us what's working for
him and i love it when creators come
together and share their secrets
and he said you know chris i'm not
taking advantage of this but you need to
get on the shorts thing he gave me some
rules
some guidelines on what to do
immediately thereafter i called my team
i said guys we got to get on the shorts
thing
follow these rules start looking at the
content and cut it down
and so like okay how often do we need to
do this and i told them just try
to drop one a day they're not that hard
to do because they have to be under one
minute long
and we would post videos and two or
three weeks into it the team
we had a we had a call and the chris do
you want us to continue doing this
they're not really taking off now here's
the crazy thing
i think from day one to day 27 or day 28
the video is just moving along just like
everything else on our channel it took a
little while for the algorithm to figure
it out
and that video went bananas in four days
i think it hit seven million views in
four days
i'll tell you a funny story i was
calling one of my friends talking to him
hey did you check out this video
i think it's gone kind of viral it's got
like 130
000 views and he's like let me look at
his channel he said no there's nothing
here there's one with 300 000 views
i'm like oh my god we have two hits
right now
i go back i can't find 130 000 viewed
video
it had grown by from 130 000 to 350 000
in the two hours in which i looked away
and it kept going nuts i've never had a
video go like that before
we're happy when our videos hit 50 000
videos or views
in a week or two weeks this is unheard
of and it's just going nuts and i just
keep looking at it
and it's the craziest coolest thing that
was for me
my mr beast moment i i wonder this is
how it must feel to be mr
beast when you just look at your video
bananas in day one yeah
so it took a little while for it to take
off man that's incredible and i mean 22
million views already and continuing to
to grow but i'm sure uh listeners
now the the question burning in their
mind
is what were the rules that uh talking
with brian elliott
uh that he shared with you and what are
some of the tips you can pass along for
making great shorts
this is gonna sound super obvious to
anybody's listeners like
chris is no genius and i'm not i just
follow people's rules and i just
apply he said make sure your video is
less than a minute long because
sometimes
the youtube machine adds a little
overhead to the video
and if it goes one frame over one minute
it's not gonna
be considered as a short so just keep it
under so he's like 59.5 seconds no
problem
that's totally cool he said also you
have to use the hashtag shorts
and then just go at it and that's all he
said he just do it and do it for some
time because it takes a while
for the algorithm to pick it up so what
did we do so here's some
insight if you go back into your
archives and look at your highest
performing videos
and you look at the retention graph it
usually is a good indicator as to your
editing team
on what parts to pull out whenever you
see a spike someone's rewound it
watch it again that's a good indication
but like many things
if you just take your hits and you make
little hits out of it
there's a good chance that one of them
is going to catch like fire
a couple other things i noticed about
the videos that have performed really
well
usually it's me saying something a
little controversial that goes against
conventional wisdom
i'm going to challenge a sacred cow to
get people to turn their head
and it's emotional and people are really
angry sometimes at our shorts
they see this and there's not saying
very nice things the trolls do come out
and it's actually really fun for me to
read so if you can touch
a nerve and say something that
challenges people's
uh the way that they see the world if
there's a good chance they're gonna tune
into it
wow that's brilliant we like to talk
about having a polarizing point of view
not just to pick a fight for picking a
fight's sake but when it's a true
conviction
um getting people to stop you like i
like that you said that it's like trying
to get people to stop the scroll hang on
that video
um and you've continued now to post
shorts um do you have a
current content schedule or rhythm or
are you trying to
is it set in stone or at least written
down
on paper or in slack or base camp or
somewhere
that you're posting a couple full length
videos a week are you trying to do seven
shorts a week what's your current rhythm
the current rhythm is we're gonna drop
five shorts a week
we generally release them at seven a.m
pacific daylight time monday through
friday
every once while i'm experimenting with
dropping one on the weekend because we
have a huge catalog
of shorts to drop so i'm just trying to
figure out the right cadence
we will drop two longer when i see
longer it's like five minutes ten
minutes long
episodes on tuesdays and thursdays at
seven a.m so when we do that
the shorts get bumped down to nine a.m
and as far as i can tell there is no
penalty on how many
shorts you can drop so right now we're
going all in on the shorts
it's helping our channel to grow in subs
in views
in in time watched and also in revenue
it's very important to us
let me put this in perspective when i
look at our subscriber graph
prior to using shorts prior to any of
this stuff happening
we're getting on average about three to
four hundred subs a day
which you know a couple years ago i
would be kicking the screen and saying
this is freaking amazing i'm so happy
about this
but when the shorts hit our subs grew by
fifteen hundred percent
so we went from three four hundred subs
a day
to thousands of subs a day at one point
i think we're hitting six or
seven thousand subs a day and holding
that over multiple days
so we're starting to smash past all of
our sub
sub goals for the year that is
absolutely unreal so
you would say is there any scenario
where you would tell a listener to not
be at least considering shorts right now
and what would you tell somebody who's
on the fence like
will it will it offend my current
viewers it's so different
these don't have thumbnails they don't
need thumbnails will it you're a design
guy and i like that you said earlier
you know kind of like practicality over
you know the look of things because it
sort of messes up the channel aesthetic
on desktop
you know what would what would your
advice be for people leaning into shorts
when there's an hesitation there i think
like many things give something a try
and then
reserve judgment for 30 or 45 days just
to see
don't let fear be the thing that decides
what you're going to do
and ultimately you have to ask yourself
what matters more to me
to reach more people to be able to gain
an influence
and to develop some authority over what
it is that i do
or to have the the best designed best
thumbnail channel that nobody's ever
heard of
and if you look at it like that then
you're going to go for the results and
impact
versus what it is that you want at the
end of the day if you love a particular
color and a particular typeface
but no one cares about that you're then
you're just saying i'm an artist i'm
just going to do it for me
and so yes you're right sean the
thumbnails don't even get seen on mobile
and so my team was spending hours making
thumbnails for shorts
and yeah it does affect desktop but
people are not really watching shorts
on desktop they're really doing this on
mobile so at that point i said i would
rather spend the time and energy
making better shorts than i would trying
to design a thumbnail
yes aesthetically it's all over the
place there's weird faces that i have
like i don't even care
if if it gets watched and it helps
people that's at the end of the day what
matters to me
now you mentioned that it also has
increased revenue
um where does youtube short's revenue
come from for us
certainly if it's viewed on desktop
there's desktop
ads that can play but on shorts are you
familiar
and i don't know if i'm updated yet on
if
video ads play there or if youtube
premium members you get a little bit of
that revenue
are you able to track that revenue we
are uh the
because the length of the shorts and how
ads are working
you don't expect to make a lot of money
or any money at all
so that 22 million viewed video i think
we made a couple hundred bucks on it not
a lot
but what it's doing is it's bringing in
a whole new audience
that has no idea who we are and they
start to dig into the content
and that's really where we see the
increase in revenue so our cpm for our
channel
i think is around thirty dollars per
thousand views
and so on a regular month we can expect
to do anywhere between nine
to twelve thousand dollars in in in
google adsense revenue
when the shorts started to hit and our
channels started to spike
we got as high as 23 000 for a month
of course we can't maintain that but if
we keep at that trajectory
we're basically doubling our revenue wow
there you go so i think you just hit a
real powerful unlock point there
and it's the kind of entourage effect
the synergy
of posting these shorts you have some
long-form
content you've also of course built out
a whole business model
and when it comes to getting awareness
building influence meeting people you've
never met before
and 22 million views i mean that kind of
speaks for itself
and even the long tail of that i mean a
10
result if someone had a breakout video
would be like 2.2 million one percent
would be 200 000 views that's a lot of
exposure
and that attention can then lead to the
other videos on your channel or the
other things that you're doing inside
of your business now in a second i'm
actually curious
and you've made a few references um in
this podcast
about your team helping you and your
team helping you with thumbnails
i actually want to talk about the team
you've built around your youtube channel
in a second but of course
many people are listening or like great
chris
you know your team you know is helping
you
uh i just i said hey team let's do some
shorts and of course that's the reality
we're in
at think media as well um with 18 people
on the team now and a couple different
content creators i know you've got
different content creators
uh you know personally though i started
shooting videos in my bedroom i started
uh editing doing all wearing all the
hats myself that's my journey and going
through every stage of
having a side hustle season where i had
other jobs and careers
having the solopreneur season where i'm
trying to build the business just by
myself and now we're in the scale season
where of course there's others on the
think media
team helping um chris before we talk
about the team aspect
what advice would you give for the
solopreneur
in terms of getting content done leaning
into youtube
while maybe especially in your tribe
having to do the client work do the
freelance work
go in and clock in for their creative
director job or whatever it is
and do this stuff on the side what are
some of your tips
okay tip number one is to try to figure
out a cadence that works for you
this should not add additional stress
for you and if it does you have to
rethink why you want to do something
like this because
that means that you're looking at the
reward and this is now
not a labor of love it's just labor and
if you approach it with that mindset and
if
the cadence is killing you you're going
to get stressed out and you're not going
to perform your best
so in the very beginning our release
schedule was probably two episodes a
month
and it wasn't anything that we had to go
all in on you want to just put in the
time
to practice to be able to be comfortable
on camera it is a weird thing sean i
know you know this
but looking into a piece of glass is the
weirdest thing
ever that's not a human there's no
emotion it doesn't laugh at you
it doesn't lean in you just speak to
something and there's zero feedback and
it makes you feel really disregulated
it takes some time to be able to
overcome the awkwardness
of speaking to yourself in normal
circles people who talk to themselves
are considered a little crazy you have a
few screws loose
so just put in that time and don't worry
too much about trying to hit any
particular metric
so when you're inspired jot down some
ideas keep
a notebook of ideas so that when you're
ready to make those two episodes
you kind of have something to draw on
and it's not just a blank slate where
you're sitting there asking yourself
what am i going to do today here's
another tip i would give to you
you got to find something that people
really care about so there's the things
you care about
but maybe you're a very unique person
and no one actually is looking for that
so it's good for you to start reading
and participating in other people's
communities it could be on youtube
it could be on linkedin instagram or
twitter
find something that stirs people's
emotions and see
if someone has answered it in a way
that's satisfactory
and if they haven't that's an
opportunity for you
again you're looking for those gaps in
the marketplace or maybe you have an
idea to do it differently a new and
novel way of conveying the same
information well that's your opportunity
there
so if you have limited time make sure
you spend it
towards something that people actually
care about and need to know the answer
to
that's amazing find that cadence
heather taurus on the think media team
says it's your race your pace
and we don't all have the same extra
time in the week i mean some of our
jobs demand 40 50 60 hours depending on
what it is maybe some overtime
salaried positions that have a lot of
very intense seasons or maybe you can
budget more time per week
what's that cadence so that you can
experiment with youtube shorts so that
you can
stay consistent with one upload a week
or whatever it is but of course the goal
of what we would recommend
is that you start to figure out how to
generate revenue from your side hustle
so it can become your main hustle
and then eventually that you don't do
this alone
maybe eventually you get help with video
editing you maybe get a personal
assistant or somebody that could take
other things off your calendar
off your to-do list so that you can
focus on what you do best and scale your
content the future
is uploading over this last month a
video a day when you add all their
videos together so that's
that's an intense schedule and chris i'm
curious
um how do you have the team set up
around your youtube
channel now what roles and and how many
people are working on the channel and if
you could
maybe walk us through the seasons
because there's maybe today but
what was maybe that initial team when
things started to
you know kind of the 1.0 version i mean
you guys are
at scale or you know you're zero to a
hundred now like you're
a video a day the quality of the content
obviously the results you're getting
when i checked around 12 million views
in the last month which is just
crazy results so talk about the seasons
of team and what specific roles you've
put in place
sure i forget exactly how many people
work for us
right now maybe there's like 15 people
or 14 i i don't know
but the content team is actually a lot
thinner than it seems because there's a
whole nother side to our company where
we're authoring courses and doing
marketing
so i think right now we have three
full-time
editors slash producers who work on the
channel itself
and we're running two youtube channels
there's yet another youtube channel that
we're running
and between the three editors they're
editing
content that mostly i've recorded or
perhaps ben burns or greg gunn who might
record an episode or two
they're more sporadic creators where i'm
the consistent person pumping out the
content
and so that's the team that's dedicated
towards our youtube channel effort
so it's about three or four people now
did we always have this
of course not it began with just mostly
me
and jose this is like our what we'll
call the year one
where a rookie season and it was just us
writing the content ourselves doing the
keynote
at this point i have a production
company that makes commercials so i'm
just using the equipment
and the team that we already have so i'm
borrowing from peter to pay paul kind of
thing
so it didn't cost us anything really
extra but we use the space and the
cameras and equipment
and so that's how we're able to
subsidize the launch of the future
many of you guys may be in a similar
position where you're a professional
videographer
maybe you're a sound recorder something
like that so you're going to borrow some
of the tools you already have so you're
not building this up from scratch and
making
a huge financial investment up front and
as
as we continue to become successful we
started out bringing
on a volunteer somebody who really
didn't have a lot of skills and wanted
to learn
how to create content how to shoot how
to edit they're passionate
uh the first guy we had his major was in
finance
and so then he wanted to become a
cinematographer and so he looked at like
hey this is a great exchange in value
i'll give you my labor i need to learn i
need to up my game
and so we begin with some volunteers
quickly move them into paying positions
and the team starts to grow
the first person you probably want to
hire or to bring on your team
is someone to do the editing editing can
take a really long time
and it takes a person to understand your
tone
your style and what's important in the
content not just technically
here's how you make an edit yeah and
what you said
at that last part was gold you said it
takes a person that
understands your style your tone and
the nuance of editing it's maybe not
enough to just be able to edit a video
we call them
shreditors if they can sometimes help be
a shooter an editor and a producer
i'm curious out of the three helping now
if you were to give them one of your
uh workshops or lectures at 60 minutes
long you're teaching on a whiteboard
without any direction would they pull
out
the best five minutes here the best 12
minutes there
and think about the the hook the angle
the title
or is there a synergy where there is
somebody that's kind of speaking into
that and then they're executing on the
edits
um that is a real art form and so i'm
just kind of curious
about uh do you do you coach and mentor
in that is somebody
overseeing and are you pointing people
to parts or are they pulling those parts
out on their own and doing every step in
the youtube process
they're doing most of the heavy lifting
today
i basically tell them i'm interested in
doing this kind of thing they'll ask me
a few questions and based on what i tell
them
they'll know how to set it up what
cameras where to put them
what's moving what's operating what's
static and they pretty much know what to
do
so the minute i walk onto the set and we
have an office space so there's multiple
sets that we use
they're like does this look good to you
and they know i'll be wearing a cap and
they want to make sure the reflections
aren't going to be a problem
so they figured out most of that i might
arrive on set and make
one or two small adjustments but then we
just get going
and so they'll shoot and everything is
good one person's live cutting
usually we're live streaming and they'll
use that and export the edl and then
make the longer form
like better looking cut based on that
edl so we're trying to do as much work
up front and being smart about how we do
things
when possible and what they'll do is
they'll cut the video together
there's an internal review process using
frame
frame i o and the editors will look at
it they'll comment
they now at this point know exactly what
it is that i'm looking for and how i
want to do things
so i have very little involvement then
it gets uploaded to the channel
and this is like the first time i'll see
it i will figure out
what the actual title is they'll do
their best to try to come up with the
title
fill in all the descriptions the links
and all that kind of stuff that's all
done automatically
and then what i do is i design the
thumbnail i tweak the title make sure
it's something that people can find
and then i figure out when it's going to
be released now the shorts are all
automated they figured out the cadence
they know exactly which episodes to drop
i may make a tweak to the schedule here
and there but other than that it goes on
autopilot
man a couple questions out of there one
um
you do the title and the thumbnail more
or less that's
essentially the big idea that's that's
the hook that's the kind of marketing
angle that's to get attention angle
is there a reason why i mean we
understand the value of that
do you maintain kind of creative control
there because it's an art form because
of the level of study you've done and
and uh is that yeah what's kind of your
vision behind
being that final piece and how important
is that title and thumbnail that you
take that stage i think the title and
thumbnails
everything if you don't title it
properly the world's best video is not
going to be seen
and what i do is i'm a very much a data
data-driven person
so when a video drops and it's not
hitting the numbers that i think it
should be hitting
i look into the numbers what is what is
it called the re not the retention
it's called impression click-through
rate and that's really important
so when that's not working i think
something wrong with the thumbnail is
something wrong with the title
and i'm making adjustments in real time
i also think that
as the person who reads and responds to
every comment on all our social channels
me i have a pretty good sense of what
our audience is looking for
i understand their pain points and
challenges sometimes the team
can get lost in titling that they assume
someone is already smart enough to know
what the problem is
so they're searching for this very
specific solution so my general tip to
everybody that's
trying to figure out what what title
call their videos use
really basic language like a fifth
grader
dumb it down a little bit because people
who don't know the answer
don't know the terminology so make it
simple make it intuitive
and make sure you're checking this
against what people are searching for
to make sure that this is really what
they're looking for
amazing advice uh secondly to that
what you just shared a moment back
around the process of even the shorts
being published i'm curious
that 23 million viewed short now is
titled
why charging by the hour doesn't make
sense and i'm curious
was that picked out by your team and was
it just a moment that maybe was going to
be solid did you expect it to go
to go viral if you will i guess what i'm
asking
is did you architect that moment being
turned into a short or was it just one
of many and that one happened to
uh pop off um i don't remember because
the process is so fluid sean
i'm gonna just assume my team came up
with that title usually what i do is i
read the titles i think to myself
if i'm an average person looking for a
solution is this what i would be typing
in
and every once in a while they get a
little too tricky with the titling
and i'll just change it it could because
it's phrased in a way that i don't think
anybody would type in
to google i i think you guys did a video
on on your channel
about auto filling and just typing in
things and seeing what people are typing
in
and it's not always the language that
you think it is and
i had a feeling that this video was
going to do well because of a couple
things
it was cut down from already our most
popular video our most widely viewed
video
so there's a good chance if we don't
screw it up it's going to be seen again
but i think the way this video was
created was one of my editors
grabbed some clips and dropped it on
tick tock
and seeing how that performed a
different editor
grabbed those same clips and brought
them together glued them back together
to make a minute long thing
so there's a lot of testing going on
here behind the scenes that's done
more of it on an intuitive level take
your popular video
drop it somewhere else it's working take
those videos back glue them together and
repurpose it
and there's a good chance it's going to
be hit you know how people like bacon
and they like certain things like
truffle oil it's like if you know people
like this
you put it in your sandwich they're
gonna like it it's kind of like that
that's some think media podcast gold
what's the most popular video on your
channel that's already proven
can you cut some clips out of it and use
for shorts and even
test those somewhere else on tick tock
or reels
and and then potentially turn them into
a youtube shorts
that's an action item think media
podcast and i think that
um that's something definitely that uh
has proven to work
for chris and i'm excited uh to even
share this very episode with our team
because um we have not quite done that
yet we haven't taken
we have a lot of quote-unquote hits and
so to narrow some of those down and to
chop some of those up
amazing advice chris really appreciate
it well um
i in a second i'm excited to talk about
some of your general advice
for this next decade in the creative
economy um
for your encouragement and warning and
the mistakes people make as creative
business owners
but one of the things i love about you
is your commitment to
always level up your learning we believe
that lifelong leaders
are lifelong learners and
you um read a lot of books in fact you
wrote a book
pocket full of dew and
dough i should say pocket full of dough
and
people can get that we'll put that in
the show notes as well you could tell us
a little bit about that but i'm curious
what books do you recommend for
creatives and entrepreneurs
that would help them specifically with
online marketing
and youtube growth specifically okay
i would recommend a couple of marketing
books because we're in the marketing
space
i think you can't go wrong with picking
up a seth godin book i loved
this is marketing and permission
marketing and all marketers are liars
those are three really good books you
don't need to read all of them but those
are pretty good
a lot of people like alan dibb's book
the one page marketing plan
because it puts together a step-by-step
process and people like that
some people like donald miller's book
storybrand
and any any books around storytelling or
branding
right now i'm finishing up kendra hall's
book stories that stick
wonderful book about how to tell stories
and she's an amazing gifted storyteller
and it's very practical and pragmatic
two other books i'm gonna recommend
and and this is based on my belief that
good writing trumps good design
so you need to learn to write better but
it's not about writing a novel
it's just about learning how to write
punchier and more succinctly and to
communicate more clearly
neville medora's book this book will
teach you how to write better excellent
resource you can read that book
probably in an hour and a half it's very
thin very few words and it's awesome
i'm also reading joseph sugarman's book
on copywriting and the copywriters
the guide to copywriting or something
like that those are excellent books too
we if we study the people whose
livelihood depends on getting people to
pay attention
namely people in advertising and
copywriting there's a lot of lessons you
can learn
including how to title your episodes
man i knew you're going to bring the
fire with some recommendations there
and we will summarize that um think
media podcast listeners in
the not just the show notes but we'll
make like a kit dot co of that as well
because it's a question we get a lot
and tell us a little bit about
your book i actually just ordered it and
i saw
it looks beautiful not only is there of
course you bring the design
aspect to things but tell us a little
bit about it and how that could help
uh those listening yeah the the book is
actually
just our fans our audience saying this
would be great if you can just put your
ideas into a book and mostly it was just
from tweets but tweets as you know are
pretty short
and so i was struggling with this and i
started to collect together
and this is just me using data my
highest performing tweets
and that was the foundation of the book
and the book is broken up into set
different chapters about pricing about
communication about mindset
uh about negotiations i forget now what
what all the chapters are
and i started to write now being a
designer i felt a little insecure about
my
ability to write so each page is paired
with a beautiful graphic that was
designed by my designer to kind of marry
the idea
conceptually visually and then it's
paired with just one page
i i look at it like this if you're
looking for
really bite-sized pieces of information
without a lot of fat on the bone
that's my book my complaint about how
many authors write
is they have a central thesis and then
they just tell that
over and over and over again i'm
relatively smart i get the idea i don't
really want to read
55 stories that say the same thing but
it seems like a lot of books are written
this way
so i wanted to take the opposite
approach there's a bunch of different
ideas
that are organized in a very specific
way and it very much
comes from my philosophy and it gathers
together
all the different things that i've read
and have influenced me
in one single volume man i can't
wait till to crack and do it myself it's
in the mail for me right now and i would
highly recommend
um think media podcast checking it out
you know one of my filters
for who i like to learn from is those
with proven results with
proven experience with depth of wisdom
we believe that wisdom's the principal
thing
um and so with chris's experience
in film in design
um with working with huge brands with
getting punched in the face as an
entrepreneur
with uh all the ups and downs um
definitely
worth your while and super inspiring it
kind of reminds me
of um i love the book by
paul arden's book yep like that are a
little bit
they're refreshing um because they sort
of bring
some big ideas off the page any other
books top of mind i'm just as a personal
question
you could any what are your top five
books personally about any topic that
have really transformed your life's
life chris you know you might not know
that off top of your head but you can
give me as many three to five
okay i could do it actually because i've
made a list and the list keeps getting
edited because
i read a new book i'm like i gotta bump
one book off the list
so number one jim rohn's book seven
strategies for wealth and happiness
i think that's an incredible book number
two i just finished reading this book
and i think it knocked somebody else off
the list there
the one thing by gary keller the one
thing by gary keller
a book number three i would probably
recommend somebody read
the brand flip by marty newmeier i think
it's an excellent book
book number four the win without
pitching manifesto by blair ends
excellent book reframes your whole
thinking about price and
how you position yourself in the
marketplace the fifth book
is the coaching habit by michael bungay
stanier it's a poorly titled book
because i'm not looking to be a coach
but what's in it is a framework of six
or seven questions that i think are
beautiful
and he explains the importance of why
questions matter
because they empower people and you can
be seen
as a greater authority as more helpful
as being more generous if you just learn
how to ask better questions
and i ordered i still need to crack into
it but i got the coaching habit when i
heard you talk about it on clubhouse
and so um i'll tell you what i'm doing
after this podcast
chris is i'm heading to amazon and uh
i'm buying every book you recommended um
it's a new decade and as we land the
plane today
especially because you have your pulse
on creativity
you consult big brands on
what's happening with demographics and
psychographics and how to stand out in
the marketplace
and as an expert in the context of this
podcast
you are incredibly effective on social
media and youtube
what do you foresee uh for the future of
social media and youtube
over the next decade
wow okay that's powerful so we're seeing
a trend move
towards influencers and micro
influencers being the gateway to
audiences
and demographics and i think big brands
are already seeing this because we're
starting to see more money move into
this space
and i i've said this before but i don't
think
everybody's hearing what i'm saying on
this part all companies
are media companies they just don't know
it yet
so they're the the old days of you
making commercials and trying to gain
influence and persuade people
and making impact on their purchasing
and the decisions that they make
it seems to be almost over so you might
as well start to learn how to create
content
in a way that you can speak directly to
your audience and we really believe in
this
this is a bias opinion i'm just going to
throw this out there that if you want to
sell
to more people you have to learn how to
be a better educator you have to teach
people about your products or services
if you're a non-profit you need to teach
them about the impact that you're making
the world
the difference that you're creating and
i think that's what really matters
so everyone that is a company whether
you're a service or product based
company
you need to learn how to tell better
stories you need to understand how these
platforms work and create content
natively on each platform you don't need
to dominate all of them
just a handful find a home base and then
build out from your home base
wow and as we maybe pivot that question
so powerful as far as your insight is
um for the creative business owner
many people listening maybe are just
getting started and they're
in the early days maybe just kidding you
know like we were once
where we're like i hope this works um
you know one day at a time like
i'm in a i'm in a garage right now
bootstrapping this whole thing together
um for the journey ahead in this and we
really believe this next decade is going
to be the best decade in the crater
economy as you mentioned influencers
micro influencers
the world is wide open to lean into that
but it's not going to be without work
and without challenge
what encouragement warnings or advice
would you give creative business owners
for the journey ahead
wow i can give them a lot of different
advice can you help me to narrow that
question down a little bit sean
let's go warnings um what kind of
warnings
that maybe you've had to overcome that
caused you to
lose profit lose time um
get distracted what are maybe some
pitfalls people could fall into that
could
hurt their growth specifically of trying
to
build their influence on social media
wonderful thank you for clarifying that
narrowing it down for me
my biggest warning for anybody who's
creating content whether you're a
multi-billion dollar corporation or
mom-and-pop with a grocery
store or a restaurant or something like
that which is
don't try to take any of these shortcuts
they will hurt you
don't try any of these growth hacking
bot things where
you're trying to grow really really fast
in a way that's not organic and real
and there are many people who will take
your money and do these things
and give you the results that you asked
for but later on you're going to realize
these people were either bought or paid
for and they're not really there for you
the best kind of audience begins with a
true and authentic relationship with
your audience your community
you show up for them they will show up
for you if you do this consistently over
time
they get a sense of who you are your
personality but it builds trust
which is the key to your brand trust is
everything
and so it's hard to earn and it's easy
to lose
so don't be in a rush to get your
results just show up do the work
hire a few smart people to coach and
teach you and just follow the plan
and everything will work out if you stay
in the game long enough
the chris doe man such valuable wisdom
listen
people need to follow you and connect
with what you're doing um especially on
instagram
the future your personal account i swear
in the future i think i i
click save on every post because you
make these carousels that are so rich
in value your personal instagram as well
shout out some accounts and anything
that uh
we can connect with in the think media
podcast community to follow you
and continue to learn from you thank you
you can find me on most social platforms
i'm at the chris doe and does spell d o
i'm on instagram on linkedin twitter
youtube of course everywhere else
and the company the the media company
that i run
is called the future and the future is
spelt without an e it's f-u-t-u-r
so if you search for the future also on
social media especially on youtube
you'll find us there
as well brilliant chris well i
appreciate you so much
thanks for taking time today to pour
into us and
uh we will talk soon thanks sean
are you ready to start or grow your
youtube channel
do you feel stuck and need help
connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
youtube success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com
[Music]
[Music]